donc le cfcm conseil français du culte
musulman est un organisme qui a presque
vingt ans d'existence fondée en 2003 il
traverse une sorte de crise
d'adolescence à la fois en interne il ya
beaucoup de batailles pour la
représentation l'organisation de des
musulmans de france mais aussi à
l'extérieur dans la communauté musulmane
où beaucoup critiquent l'existence du
conseil français du culte musulman
considérant qu'il ne fait pas assez pour
les musulmans il ne serait ce pas
suffisamment aux jeunes musulmans bref
conte beaucoup considèrent à l'intérieur
que cet organisme national n'est pas
assez représentée au niveau des régions
au niveau des départements et donc ils
vont s'atteler à mieux décentralisée en
quelque sorte cette représentation c'est
très important parce que sur le terrain
beaucoup considèrent que le csm est
quelque chose de national parisien qui
n'a rien à voir avec les réalités de la
base est souvent sur ces questions de
culte musulmans qui sont parfois des
actions très concrètes de carrés
musulmans de cimetières des choses n'ont
pas toujours des fautes politiques ou ou
ayant trait à la l'extrémisme il faut
des règles d'aidés gestion de problèmes
régionaux et donc ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est la
représentativité du cube de ceux qui
sont élus pour représenter le culte
musulman est un système trop compliqué
je veux pas y venir qui associe des élus
mais aussi des personnalités cooptées
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup trop de
personnalités cooptées et les gens de la
base ne se sont pas représentés donc
c'est le deuxième enjeu troisième enjeu
évidemment l'arrêt d'égalisation toutes
les instances les autres des différentes
associations musulmanes sont évidemment
vent debout contre les extrémistes
musulmans et les terroristes je pense
que sur le principe car aucun problème
tout le monde veut lutter contre ce
phénomène mais il ne trouve pas toujours
les moyens de le faire et ça
effectivement l'état français mais chez
les français attendent de la communauté
musulmane qui elles arrivent par
elle-même à réguler ce problème de
l'extrémisme musulman